it's Friday naturally things are blowing
up especially Dan Vinci knows news
explosion our former favorite former
Secret Service agent in New York City
cop here to rank the top three stories
of the past week dan bungee no joins us
nice hey Dan hey Tucker how are you I'm
always happy because my favorite segment
of the week so let's get right to it
most explosive story of the week numero
tres number three Joe Biden discovers
the money fairy and wants to give health
care to people in the country illegally
Tucker if you heard this one this one's
fascinating yeah so Tucker when you
factor out the United States the world
has seven billion people of course
there's no rate limiting factor to
providing health care for everyone so
how we're gonna afford that I have no
idea but don't worry Tucker Joe Biden
will figure it out in conjunction with
the money fairy he's got this crazy how
that happens all right explosive story
number two of the week
China gets a taste of its own medicine
president Trump hammers China back with
25% tariffs you know Tucker I am a free
trader you know I know you probably are
too but China is not trading fairly you
know we thought when they joined the WTO
they would handle themselves a little
differently more prosperity more freedom
that's not what happened it's become the
world's largest surveillance state and
you know I in my opinion I'm a free
trader again but good for President
Trump for fighting back this is a very
important story all right this is big
this is the gold medal of stories this
week I have spent a little time on this
one this is critical Jerry Nadler Jerry
Nadler who's competing with Adam shift
and Eric swallower who can be the
biggest hack in Congress right now Jerry
Nadler is filing contempt charges
against the Attorney General Bill bar
for not producing a report Tucker that
you and I can get on our iPhones right
now you can actually go to did you know
this Tucker you could go this may be
breaking news you get on your laughing
but you could go to Amazon right now or
Barnes & Noble or whatever you want to
do and actually pick up a copy of the
Muller report that Jerry Nadler
to file criminal charges against bill
bar for not producing you know are we
living in peak stupid or oh me and you
crazy or we living in like peak stupid
right now you realize do that the one
piece of the redaction Jerry Nadler
wants that bill bar cannot produce
because it's Congress's own law rule 6 e
do you find that a little confusing
Tucker like you can buy the mullah
report he's saying he can't get and then
the redactions he wants he can't get
because Congress created this law
Federal Rule 6 e again we are living in
the dumbest of times I'm really sorry to
have to do that to your audience reminds
me of Billy Madison we remember that
said that seen a Billy Madison we're all
Dumber for having heard that right now
and and degrading to hating this much
diminishes people and they have been
diminished I mean I think Jerry Nadler
was never that impressive but he wasn't
like a fawn buffoon as he is today
embarrass ya dam bungee doesn't make you
feel bad that these people are in power
I mean really it's really pathetic I
wouldn't want to have any more power
they make me very nervous
take etc damn bungee no have the best
weekend thank you for that explosion you
too buddy see you next week